mais le tour de france a débuté dans le
drame hier soir avec la chute de chris
boardman le britannique champion du
monde du contre la montre
chris boardman a tout tenté dans le
prologue à saint brieuc sous la pluie à
la nuit tombée mais il a chuté au bout
d'une minute trente de course
il souffre d'une double fracture à la
cheville gauche et au bras droit thierry
clopeau et alain poirier l'on
rencontrait sur son lit d'hôpital avant
qu'il ne reparte pour manchester
je prends quelques points mais je trouve
plus et voilà dix ans j'ai connu je suis
à 50 du cirque matériel de
franchissement donc je pense que c'est
possible pour gagner des prologues ainsi
gagné le prologue au jeu trop ambitieux
pour les dix ans
cela passe tout le plus mauvais un
virage
l'apal en face ils sont maîtres c'est
fini je suis troy dessus ça se passe
quasiment premier un petit métier pour
fait la grande course de trois semaines
avec l'escroc
voilà c'est première opportunité pour
penser malgré un supplément aux ti vct
su mais ce concert à la future le
docteur m'a dit 7-6 6 même de moi ce que
j'ai cassé les deux
après moi je pense tout de suite c'est
pas si pour la charger du monde
donc j'ai essayé pour le championnat
mais souvient il albert la dernière il
avait nettement chuté après la super ça
va même la merci crise